Speaker 1: Okay. Next, Lauren Boebert story.
Lauren Boebert has been reported to the FBI
for allegedly inciting violence by saying
that we need to terminate the presidency
of Joe Biden. Now, she doesn't say impeachment.
She doesn't say 25th Amendment. She says terminate
the presidency of Joe Biden. And now she has
been reported to the FBI. Newsweek Lauren Boebert
reported to FBI after terminate this presidency
tweet. Lauren Boebert has been reported by several
users. The House Republican from Colorado on
Sunday appeared to mock President Joe Biden
after he mistakenly said presidency
instead of pregnancy when discussing
abortion rights being restricted in the
US following the revoking of Roe v Wade.
In response to her tweet. Actually, let's look at
the tweet first. Quote, We need to terminate this
presidency and quote, repeat the line.
Unfortunately, you can't just terminate things
you don't want. Lauren, we've got to see this out
through it's full term. And this is really getting
into fascistic rhetoric, particularly in light
of a former world leader just being assassinated.
It doesn't feel like an overreaction to say that
Lauren Boebert should be investigated over this
and the term is stochastic terrorism. I've told
you guys about this before. Stochastic terrorism
is when you have a large enough audience
that if you feed an idea to enough people,
it starts to become statistically likely that
someone will act on it. So for example, when
you are I don't know. Tucker Carlson and if you
were if he were and he's not doing this exactly,
but if he were to every night say, we need
someone to deal with Joe Biden in a permanent way.
Okay. He's not saying go out and kill Joe Biden,
but with a large enough audience, it would start
to become predictable that someone's going to
try to act on what Tucker Carlson is saying
in exactly the violent way that he is implying
it. This is not hypothetical. We have seen these
incidents happen in the past there. There's
this guy, Glenn Beck. I believe he still is on
the blaze, maybe. I think Glenn Beck is associated
with the blaze, a right wing outlet where when he
had a program on again, I'm thinking back, I
think it was on Fox, although was it CNN now?
I don't even remember. He became obsessed with
hammering on the Tides Foundation. The Tides
Foundation. It's a it's an enemy. It's evil.
It's all this different stuff. And California
Highway Patrol ended up actually pulling a
guy over who was on his way to do violence
to the Tides Foundation because he heard Glenn
Beck talk about it. Now, could you hold Glenn
Beck legally liable for that? No. Now, if it was
significantly more direct than maybe you could,
but in that way, you're not going to hold Glenn
Beck legally liable. But stochastic terrorism is
a cultural phenomenon. If you continue hammering
on whoever, then these things are going to happen.
A more recent example during the pandemic,
Donald Trump talking about the China virus.
China did. It never should have happened. There
have to be consequences. They must be punished and
on and on and on. And it leads to just on the
street hate crimes against people believed to
be of Asian and Pacific Islander origin. And we
saw it in the United States. Random Asian women
punched, knocked down, knocked out. In some
cases, some of these things caught on video.
Is Trump legally liable? No. Did he say go out and
punch random Asian people on the street? No. But
from our cultural understanding, we would
start to realize, oh, it's going to become
likely that that will happen when you have a
large enough platform and you start putting these
messages into people's minds. And that's exactly
what Lauren Boebert is doing here with We must
terminate this presidency. Stochastic terrorism.
It's the term we've seen it before. It's real.
And unfortunately, there I mean, there's
two sides to this one. A lot of these things
don't rise to the level of criminality.
And I'm not saying that they should.
They just often don't. And number two, there is
so much of this that law enforcement can't even
keep up. Federal law enforcement, investigative
agencies, Secret Service keeping up threats.
It's overwhelming the degree to which this type
of thing is out there. And if you listen again,
listen to the voicemail that I posted to my
Instagram and to my Twitter this morning.
You will see that these folks are
everywhere. And we've got to be very,
very cautious and concerned about them. And
Lauren Boebert is just making the problem worse